[Music]
[Music]
this is my house
this is me this is my
mom this was the desk i had quite a
small
desk and i was just sat in my laptop
and wishing i could go out and play
it wasn't as as fun as actual school
on the first day it felt weird i missed
being with my friends
so my mum was there and she helped me
if i got stuck because like
i couldn't actually go to real school to
learn so home became school
but now we know staying off school for a
long long time and doing homeschooling
isn't actually as good
as doing it in school because everyone
thought homeschooling would have been
better
but when it was in reality we had to
still do
all the work and it wasn't as good as
actual learning
at the start of this year we decided to
get a school dog
because of well-being and love really
there are 540 pupils at woodlands this
is a large
primary school in ellesmere port in
cheshire how old are you
in dog is well seven times six do we
know what seven times six is
by the time the pandemic is over most of
the children here
and millions more across the uk will
have missed months and months of time in
school
you know children have spent so long out
of the classroom that no
amount of homeschooling can match this
and it's staggering to know that nearly
two whole academic years
have been lost because of this pandemic
and millions of children
are now having to catch up for the
learning that they've lost out on
covid has turned school life upside down
and recovering from it could take years
we knew it was coming i think there was
an element of denial and if i'm honest
i was in danielle a little bit i was
thinking surely this won't happen surely
this is the stuff of hollywood movies
did i feel that they would miss out yes
i did 100 and obviously the longer that
went on the more they were missing out
good morning woodlands primary school
right
um if he's in a lateral flow test then
um
he can come into school that's not a
problem more than
600 000 pupils are currently off school
isolating
but only four percent of them actually
have the virus
if the result is positive then he will
have to stay
at home for the 10 days how regularly
does a call like that happen at the
moment
um at the moment um we probably get
possibly two calls a day two a day two
sometimes more and really the the net
result of all this
is that if a child has to self-isolate
it could be five to ten days that
they're not in school
yeah that they're not in the classroom
yeah but they're not learning as much
absolutely so we're going to start maths
now so if you can all put your date
and can i enter your books for me during
lockdown only vulnerable children
or those of key workers were allowed to
come in
the rest had to be home schooled so
how are things going for the woodhouse
family oh god
so how did you find learn from home it
wasn't
as good as learning in my actual school
because you didn't get to see your
friends and it just didn't feel the same
okay and what about you jessica it
wasn't as
fun i like the actual learning in school
what was it like for you mom tricky some
days you'd have a really positive day
we'd get loads done
and loads of accomplished you know the
kids would be really motivated and then
other days you'd find yourself
nobody wanted to get out of bed because
there was nowhere to go
it was the same it was dull it was you
know you were sat
sort of at the kitchen table thinking oh
it's you know another day of this yeah
so yeah it was a bit of a role location
of emotions and there was
tears and tantrums okay from me on them
[Applause]
jessica's seven she's missed a lot of
school
especially crucial phonics lessons
that's the method schools use to teach
reading and writing i miss my friends
definitely and and i miss
actually like being here and actually
learning like math literacy
like all the normal work stuff
my mum was actually really good my
brother
liam he helped me with my phonics
we got a pack of little phonics cards so
i could practice at home
you worry that you know academically
they're not going to be able to to keep
up maybe
with some of the other children you
worry that you've not done enough
homeschooling you're worried that you've
not kept their spirits up enough you
worry that they
you worry about everything this is
kirsty jessica's mum
she's proud of the way her daughter's
handled all of this upheaval
do you think it's the pandemic with
jessica 100
i think having that crucial time
of those years not having a full year in
school
since reception i think has been massive
on jessica what was our target number
that we started with yesterday narula
the government says it's committing an
extra 3 billion pounds to help schools
respond to the pandemic
including funding catch-up lessons like
this one
but teaching unions say this amounts to
around 50 pounds per pupil
and any shortfall has to be paid for by
schools themselves
we'll stick with a hundred to start with
i know some of you find this quite
straightforward from yesterday paul
mclaughlin's been a teacher for 30 years
he's been brought in to run some of the
government-funded catch-up classes
we've been doing a lot of working on
their times tables
because they don't know them well enough
to be able to then access
all the things with those especially
with those who struggle with their mats
anyway
um so lots of those really really
important
um key skills that they need to keep
practicing
they've they've lost them and i can see
that the the impact of them not having
those skills leaving
leaving primary school will probably not
show
until they're maybe a couple of years
older
and it's not really worrying isn't it
because the the pandemic yes it's been
it's been
15 18 months but very worrying that the
impact on education could last many many
years to come
yeah yeah yeah and i think and i think
we won't know what that is
until these children are sort of coming
towards the end of their education and
seeing if it's still impacting
on them go on 32 lovely
32 initial findings from research done
by the national association of head
teachers
shared exclusively with sky news reveals
that 87
of school leaders said the government's
covid recovery funding
was not sufficient to meet the needs of
their pupils
they also found that an average school
is down by nearly 60 000
pounds since the pandemic began that's
the extra cost of covert security
supply staff and lost income from not
being open to the community
hi izzy hi annabelle right listen i just
want to check that you're on my list
which class are you in again just remind
me
what are your worries about the way that
the pandemic has impacted your children
here
i think the challenge about separating
that from the systemic issues we've had
for years is quite tricky so schools
were already under financial pressure
beforehand
so now if you wanted to put in
additional support for children
you'd be hard pushed too because most of
us have spent extra cash on cleaning or
you know um ppe stuff etc etc
because whilst the government have
committed money to us it just hasn't it
hasn't
fulfilled that shortfall which one are
you careful
purple for you et voila
thank you we have to look like you would
with your own money
if i want to go on holiday then
something else has to give i want to buy
a new car can't go on holiday so we're
looking at all these things that we need
in a school
we want to support our most vulnerable
children
but we can't do that and support catch
up and look after the infrastructure and
do all these additional things that we
do something has to give
[Music]
on average primary school pupils fell
behind by about two months in reading
and more than three months in maths the
pandemic has had a huge impact
on millions of youngsters and their
parents
you feel that guilt you know when they
are now they're coming back and they
are struggling a little bit you you
carry that guilt you think is that my
fault
because i've not done you know i've not
done a good enough job
but then you think well i've done the
best that i could have possibly done
it feels like you're carrying all that
blame on yourself
parent i think that's what a lot of
parents do i think as a parent you feel
responsible for your children
in all respects
many children will have no problem
making up for lost time
but there's a fear that for others
learning in lockdown
will have lasting effects on their
education
nick martin sky news